welcome to my review of the latest
controversial comic book movie Captain
Marvel was directed by Anna Boden and
Ryan Fleck the team behind the
criminally underrated half-nelson really
great indie film if you've never seen
that strongly strongly suggest you check
that one out that one's really really
good and Marvel has had a really good
track history with taking directors and
writers who are primarily from an indie
background and putting them in this
universe and letting them shine so I was
really excited to see what this team
could bring to this story and here the
MCU finally is introduced to Carol
Danvers played by brie Larson she learns
about her past she discovers who she is
and she finds herself caught in the
middle of a war between two alien races
and realizes she's more powerful than
she ever knew she was know I feel like a
lot of reviews are going to say this but
I'm going to say it anyway because it's
on my mind there's a lot of hype
surrounding this movie from two
different groups some people really want
the film to fail and some people really
want the film to succeed for various
reasons it seems like a lot of agendas
are involved with this movie which is
something that's becoming very common
now for Marvel films I just want to see
a good film I don't care if it fails I
don't care if it succeeds I want to see
a well-made film made by people who
respect the artform
who are trying to tell a good story that
communicates a good message to the
people who are going to see this movie
whether that's for girls who don't
usually get the chance to see a female
hero on screen or your average audience
member who just wants to be entertained
and Captain Marvel is entertaining in
spurts there are sequences throughout
the first act and second act that I
thought were really well done namely the
chemistry between brie Larson and samuel
l.jackson as a younger Nick Fury their
arguments were clever they were funny
both of them played really well off of
each other
there was a fish out of water scenario
once Carol Danvers is on earth it
reminded me a little bit of Terminator 2
you promised me we're gonna kill anybody
why because you just can't why because
you just can't okay it's not that
exaggerated or anything but there were
scenes where she does things that are
normal to her and people are looking at
her like what the hell what is going on
here and
that was really entertaining also one of
the most praiseworthy elements of this
film is the truly truly groundbreaking
CGI de-aging work that was done to
samuel l.jackson and Clark Gregg it's
stunning after the first few scenes I
didn't even notice anymore it just
blended into the background which is
what the best CGI does the best
computer-generated stuff is the stuff
you don't even notice that's when a CGI
artist has truly met their goal when
their work is so seamless that it
doesn't even capture your attention
necessarily it just becomes part of this
world and that is just we're in the
future we're in the fucking future it is
insane what they've done here really
amazing CGI work I also liked aspects of
the opening moments you have Jude Law
and her training you have this fight
scene where she has these metal braces
on her hands and she's trying to break
them by busting her hand against a
spaceship wall and they won't shatter so
she just has to punch people really
fucking hard to try to get these things
off of her hands that was a badass scene
probably my favorite fight scene in the
movie I also like the musical score it
felt different from other Marvel films
there was an electronic hue to it I
guess it was most akin to Thor ragnaroks
score perhaps and goose the cat I like
the cat I like cats
I don't know what else to say the cat
was fucking cool
but I got to be honest I thought this
was a pretty bland and disappointing
movie otherwise especially visually the
film doesn't have much of a style this
is something that was very disappointing
to me because you look at a movie like
thor ragnarok that Taika Waititi
directed or James Gunn's work on the
gardens the galaxy or the Russo brothers
and they're very visceral intense style
that they've brought to their Marvel
films you have come to expect something
of a Marvel movie of style of feel of
voice I didn't experience any of those
things in Captain Marvel this film felt
like a series of setups where the actors
are in frame and they're performing and
they were captured on film doing
something but there's no visual style to
it it's a very bland looking movie very
dark and murky there's a fight scene in
a spaceship
where it's this very dark area with
white lights on the wall and a pop song
is playing won't spoil it for you
although the song choice I thought was
particularly obvious and I couldn't tell
what was going on I legitimately could
not tell who was who there were a few
shots where you could see close-ups and
you're like oh okay so that's Captain
Marvel oh okay that's the other person
could not tell what was going on
besides that opening sequence where she
has those metal braces on her fists
there is not a single memorable fight in
this movie not just from a visual
perspective but from a choreography
perspective we've come to expect more
out of a Marvel film than this this
feels like phase one almost and that's
not a disservice to Iron Man there was a
feel to those early Marvel movies that
felt like they were still sort of
figuring out what they were doing kind
of like Captain America the First
Avenger but even those films Joe
Johnston had a visual flair and a style
it felt like a Joe Johnston film it felt
like the filmmaker who made the
Rocketeer made the First Avenger when it
comes to this movie I can't tell who
directed it it doesn't feel like it has
any real voice of its own even from a
storytelling perspective the film comes
off very messy this is a big risk
whenever you have a character that has
elements of their past they can't
remember and they're trying to piece
together a movie like the Bourne
Identity I think did that really well
because we have someone and we just see
who they are now and they slowly learn
who they used to be and it was told in a
very interesting way because we find out
who Jason Bourne used to be through his
actions when he grabs that flashlight
that a guard tries to smack him with and
then he just takes him out in a second
through those actions you're like oh
okay this guy used to be something
fucking badass in this movie though we
learn of carol danvers pasts more
through audio and quick flashes of
things that may have happened to her
before she goes to this realm and visits
this intelligence and is supposed to
show her what she most desires and that
arc feels really wasted in the movie by
the way I won't get into it because it's
spoilers but whenever you have a
character like Carol Danvers with a
fragmented
asked it can be very difficult to tell
this story in a way that feels cohesive
while also having her punch things every
10 minutes in a really entertaining way
it also doesn't seem to know what its
tone is or what its messages
there's 90s nostalgia for like 10
minutes and then it's sort of a buddy
cop movie between her and Nick Fury and
then it's kind of a movie about
sisterhood between her and one of her
past friends and those scenes were
really kind of cute and adorable and
heartwarming if there was more of an
emotional pull to them that I actually
felt and I just didn't feel it it felt
very forced and there just wasn't enough
backstory or information to really give
a shit about those characters then the
main villains in the films are Scrolls
they can shape-shift they can turn into
anybody they can make themselves look
like anyone as long as they've seen that
person this makes for one of the most
entertaining chase sequences in the film
with Nick Fury on the road trying to
catch up to a train that Captain Marvel
is trying to infiltrate because there's
an old lady that we've all seen the
trailers one of the better scenes in the
movie for sure but they really wasted a
lot of the potential that they could
have done with these Scrolls in
shape-shifting into different things and
creating a air of mystery and deception
it's a few scenes where they use that to
their advantage but it just sort of
disappears really quickly and another
story is put in its place that also
doesn't really feel owned or warranted
but I think the biggest issue with this
film is really not what I wanted to say
and I mean this honestly I am sad to say
that I feel like brie Larson just did
not do a great job in the movie she is
definitely trying super hard to be a
good Captain Marvel and a good Carol
Danvers she's giving a lot of dedication
to this role and I do not know if it is
direction or her choices but her
character is so so wooden this is a
fish-out-of-water scenario this is
somebody who doesn't know what's going
on who reacts to things differently
we've seen that in Thor we've seen it as
I said Terminator 2 all of those movies
played those scenes for comedy and it
made those characters more likable here
it feels like the movie is almost afraid
to make light of Carol Danvers character
or show a hint of vulnerability or
human emotion which led to a performance
that felt uneven to me
I think brie Larson is crazy talented as
an actress and I really do think they
have set up great potential I'm excited
to see what else they can do with this
role and brie Larson in the future I'm
excited to see a more fleshed-out
version of this character now that this
film has been established it just feels
like a stepping stone movie it doesn't
feel like that incredibly powerful film
that a lot of us wanted to see it just
feels like filler leading to other
things featuring Captain Marvel which is
one of the most disappointing elements
of the movie is it entertaining at times
absolutely will people watch the movie
and find enjoyment in it of course but
as someone who has seen multiple Marvel
films now I expect way more out of them
I'm gonna give Captain Marvel a see guys
thank you for watching and I do suggest
seeing the film and making up your own
mind don't give in to online agendas one
way or the other just make up your own
opinion and be honest about how you feel
that's how we get better films I think
you just have to be honest and I'm being
honest the movie could have been a lot
better all that being said I do want to
give a huge shout out to the sponsor for
this video and that is expressvpn I'm
away a lot I've spent a lot of time at
conventions I'm on the road I have to go
to cafes or public places like hotels
I'm doing a lot of movie pitches to
various businesses and studios these
business trips are something I've been
doing a lot more lately ever since I
turned 30 and decided you know what I'm
gonna really try to get my movies made
and so my privacy and my safety on the
Internet is something that's important
to me
prevents them from opening bank accounts
in your name or accessing your email or
social media accounts it's super super
helpful and you can use it on tons of
different devices that app is available
on iPhone Mac Android and more so for
less than seven dollars a month you can
use this service and there's a 30-day
money-back guarantee but if you go to
expressvpn comm slash Kris stuckman you
can find out how to get three months for
free and take your internet back today
so please do check out expressvpn comm
slash Kris stuckman
find out how you can get three months of
that service for free and thank you so
much to them for sponsoring this video
and thank you guys for watching let me
know what you think of Captain Marvel if
you do see it I'm curious to see how
this one pans out for audiences and fans
alike thank you so much guys as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]